hey guys goes on Ana back here back for
an episode five a Pokemon collogues very
exciting so today we're gonna hit up a
new place that's opening called the
pokey pitstop and we're gonna show you
guys what that looks like I just wanted
to update you guys so since last episode
a few things have changed I got a
dratini
I found a wild dratini which was insane
and imac was pretty jealous of course I
also got a slow roll only 600 CP so
we're still looking forward to evolving
that slowpoke but still it's pretty cool
and we're almost level 25 and one last
thing we have to 10k eggs on the way
which we're gonna hatch today so look
forward to that look forward to level 25
and let's see what other fun stuff is
gonna happen today
what up ok guys so now we're going to go
and check this place out the Pokemon pit
stop which is kind of crazy that they
have a private business emerging all
around pokemon gold we'll see how that
goal is what it seems pretty crazy it
just goes to show you how what a
phenomenon Pokemon go is right so let's
check it out you ready are you ready
everybody loves clowns shake you with my
left my house with the camera alright
sweet you good good good
are you guys doing right now he's been
drinking to warranty or something to
have some tried donut try one of the
cupcakes no way told us Phil no Phil no
man this is the greatest don't ever and
then you got to try one too so that we
can unwrap and see the testimony yeah I
will later but right now let's just film
him eat it like and be like really
sloppy with it it's like I don't have to
try hard
Oh
Oh
for a while it was all about like going
HD with the graphics and now it's all
about retro right so cool
yeah well what's the CP dream 585 I'm
not gonna lie to you guys I was bad but
hopefully an excellent we buy it's okay
we'll get over it
we'll get through this together guys
together as you guys could see this
opening is lit
everyone's here for the Pokemon and
there's a cloud because no one's afraid
of clowns
next time might be a 2k but I think it's
affecting all right let's check it out
laughs all right why it's not another
Eevee part of the cards it's okay it's
not great but it'll do
already have one but this one's stronger
cool cool cool okay guys so here we're
here with Dustin who's the owner of the
the polecat pit stop all right so the
idea came around to basically give
pokeyman gold players a place to hang
out so instead of hanging out by a rock
and having all these pokey stops
everywhere around say were just hanging
outside you know to go outside have an
environment a safe environment for them
to relax charge their phones you know
meet other players buy some merchandise
buy some pokey man you know donuts we're
gonna have cupcakes there was gonna
graduate energy drinks just a place to
cool down you know meet other people
whoever is and go bad I'll go to the
gyms around yeah really cool concept and
we've also heard that there's been rare
Pokemon sightings are on this area we're
from the other end of town but
apparently there's been like Dragon
heights and stuff so definitely cool
place to check out and we'll put a link
in the description to your Facebook all
right yeah and then you guys can come
and check it out if you're a knight or
false
yeah and well lures on all the time they
got free Wi-Fi we got a lot of stuff
that we're just gonna keep on expanding
you know if anybody out there has any
business ideas or anything that they are
selling coconut relate or anything like
that because approach thanks awesome
thanks a lot like take care
alright guys Anna Mac saw dragon eyes
closest pull on we're freakin out what
do we do a man what do we do I don't
know like we're gonna lure so we should
we walk should we stay let's just walk
it's back in the sightings hi guys
apparently there's a Dragonite at down
the street so we're running trying to
get there literally
we've been running search for his dragon
eye and we found it you can see it on
the screen like you're trying to catch
we're gonna do everything I can to rise
berry crazy community experience right
here man this is very good on the spore
wall man please grasp
old God jumps out right away
raspberry again I'm restarting my phone
because it wasn't get the dragon I know
did you spawn
Oh
oh man
Oh Dora Dora Dora Dora oh it's so hard
like why is it all about you walk this
way
yes got it guys got high fives all of
you was the seat beat it was a high of
like almost 800 but still a dragon Isaac
hyperbeam and Dragons up sick
commentator oh we did it guys all right
guys so I just got a 2k egg it was a
Bulbasaur but that's not the craziest
stuff so after we actually got the
Dragon Knight that was right after we
talked to the owner of the store and we
were talking about it it showed up and
everyone started running we followed
them unfortunately this guy didn't get
it well I didn't show up for me guys but
he was also filming so like you know he
took one for the team you guys should
like that up just just for his effort
right there yeah it's like that channel
before them before the Dragon Knight
which you know you got respect that like
we heard this Bruce one of the workers
here didn't get it either unfortunately
i blood but man like you know if it
popped up once it can pop up again and
wow what a crazy experience oh yeah we
heard rumors that this is a hot spot for
Dragon Knights but we were like sure you
know everyone says that and then we see
it in our sightings were like okay and
then we chase down and find it pretty
crazy it's like it's like a Pokemon goal
action movie thanks guys progress
alright guys so we got this to support
the business of course but also because
it's awesome and as a memento of the day
at the amazing day where I caught dragon
eye
it kind of looks like a dragon to be
honest the color palette but yeah guys
right now we're in the car we're heading
back we're gonna actually I'm gonna do
some evolutions become level 25 right
now and I'll see you at home and I'm
about to get 20 if anyone cares they
don't all right guys I just got an
Ivysaur and I believe you that'll take
us up to the next level let's see level
25 yep
level up nice we finally got those max
potions which is very exciting I also
wanted to draw an Eevee transformation
here what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
name a trainer and people say it still
works at the pocus top place they said
it's the word
some of them believe so but you need to
log out and then log out of your account
just like close the app but sign out
sign back in that way the servers will
save it so we're gonna see and hopefully
we get up a poor yawn because it's not
found a super strong one sec so
hopefully we get a Vaporeon that's the
strongest we had so far that has
hydropump
all right guys so Animax back in the car
we're on our way home but we thought it
would be cool now to show you guys
whether that Raynor theory if logging
out of your account rather than just you
know closing the app will make a
difference this would be an amazing
Raynor took probably strongest TV ever
caught 642 so here's hoping for the best
come on aporia do you think it'll do it
man 100 I come over my notes no thinking
after the update this routed yeah my my
doubts too but nothing to lose let's see
here's hoping this open Larry I know
Oh nope nope it's over bro ours for the
update guys our hopes our hopes of
controlling what it becomes is over
oh well amazing day overnight that I
definitely never trade that dragon I
forgot for ya I can't believe it guys
until this episode we hadn't even seen a
drew team and then we go and catch
Dragonite insane if you look at the
rarest Pokemon we talked abou tabh and
air doc the last episode already hatched
to Snorlax as' and now we got a dragon
eyes the rarest Pokemon they could
actually get at this point in the game
we had a blast today and it was so much
fun talking to other Pokemon fans at the
poket pit stop and after that Dragonite
will have to come back sometime soon
until next time see you space cowboys
you